mylar balloons and how they can impact  our  power system so in the short  demonstration the mylar balloons which  has the metallic coating on the outside  will demonstrate that once they get  tangled in the lines  they can actually catch fire and cause  outages  mylar balloons are one of our leading  causes  of customer outage each year thousands  of our customers have  outages caused by mylar balloons that  get out in the wind and get tangled in  our minds  from the safety perspective it's a very  serious concern as well because  then we have to have our linemen climb  up and  try to clear those mylar balloons from  the line